On these two separate graphs right now, I put all of the parent polynomial
functions that we've talked about so far. And they're grouped according to which
ones he said had similar end behavior. Or in other words, similar behavior at
either tail of the graph moving away from to origin. However, I have added one
extra graph, we didn't talk about in this session explicitly and that's the
graph of y equals x. Remember that technically the variable x is a polynomial.
It's just a polynomial of first degree. Pretty simple. I know that it looks
pretty different from both x cubed and x to the 5th, but I do have a reason for
putting it over here. You'll see in a second. First of all though, the similar
behavior of graphs over here and of graphs over here, has led these groups of
functions to have names. All the functions on one of these two graphs are even
functions. And the other set are odd functions. So which one do you think is
which? I've labeled this set of graphs a, and this set of graphs b. Just use
your common sense to answer this question.